hello I'm Ryan and I'm David and we are
doing an instant trailer review for the
Expendables 3 official this is the first
trailer what we got last time was a
teaser and it was just kind of a series
of cameos may credits this is like a
longer series of cameos and credits so
here we go I will say that Sylvester
Stallone has made quite a comeback of a
career making music spin I mean this
these expendable movies are all about
you know 80s action stars we got Dolph
Lundgren they're very self-aware so so
far we've seen Dolph Lundgren Jason
Statham and there's Wesley Snipes Jason
Statham isn't from the 80s as we all
know right out by now but he feels like
a baby star that's a great thing about
the Expendables movies is sort of
combining all these like I wanna say
Avengers like action heroes all together
and one for like your gruff dad yeah you
know what's nice is back very happy
about that so this were the real so
there's Mel Gibson in this trailer than
the other two he was he wasn't in the
other two films that's correct
in this trailer they reveal that he is
the villain of the film now I haven't
seen the hipster in many movies since
Passion of the Christ
Pete Apocalypto and they kind of took a
break for a while for movies I feel like
there are probably various reasons
there's all sorts and Egger who you know
was governor and took it like oh yeah
ten year break Oh amazing
sporting some stubble he looks ten years
younger than he should I almost wonder
what also probably recent CGI botoxing
his face I wonder if that doesn't even
look like his nose anymore now that
looks like semester film looks the right
like his II so let's talk about Kelsey
Grammer mm-hmm when I think action I
think Frankie Frasier Crane I think some
scrambled eggs I understand what are the
lyrics um now I do need to say Kelsey
Grammer brings a sense of credibility to
this that I didn't think it would have I
guarantee the trailers or the reviews
are all there's Kellan Lutz Kellan Lutz
we just saw Ben Hercules The Legend of
something begins yes
Kelsey Grammer has Springs from
credibility I guarantee the reviews will
say things like Kelsey Grammer and is
too seen this does like so much Emily
he's just a treat there's Harrison
Harrison Ford so and gently yeah it
literally is just like the whole movie
it's a series of like teaser is all
those all credits been a longer trailer
of all credits then the whole movie is
just all credits I really hope that they
had like I wish they just credit it's
like Indiana Jones and the transporter
and rocky and Thoreau and razor all in a
movie together where they're gonna shoot
everyone like that if I they just call
that the movie I would see it yeah
Frasier Crane is friends oh yeah pretty
I mean if anyone saw Expendables to
which many people did the Chuck Norris
scene is a perfect example of that
so and for anyone wondering I looked it
up the song playing right now is bezerk
by Eminem of the Marshall Mathers LP -
watching these guys these technology is
also well David did you have you seen
the other two Expendables films yes
did you enjoy them um third they are
action movies I mean the one thing it's
like okay
they don't seem like they're heavy on
CGI and robots or anything like pickle
action superhero movies it looks like
they're really turning it up the first
two were very financially successful so
this one might actually have like the
budget necessary the last two like the
second one kind of got there the first
one has a little kind of a low budget
feel to it this one does not seem to
this is the biggest one obviously we've
seen so far and it's full of moments
like that that's the thing these movies
are very self-aware as to who these
stars are and kind of what they've meant
to pop culture in the last 30 to 40
years for some of them like Sylvester
Stallone rocky was in the seventies but
yeah I mean it's a fun trailer and
they're they're fun movies Patrick
Hughes directed yeah I think the
trailers well edited and I think the
music really sort of brings the tone of
what you expected yeah and by putting
them in him in there they're clearly
trying to get the youth audience as well
I don't know if that will be successful
but again the second one did better than
the first so so yeah I think that they
got thing Y enscape might may have a hit
on their hands yet again I wonder who
will be an Expendables for Rumour Has a
Jackie Chan was supposed to be involved
more right I don't know that I read that
something breaking news here from David
okay Oh comment below though let us know
what you think of the Expendables 3
trailer titled
yeah who do you like what do you want to
see nm Expendables for that's a good one
yeah definitely comment that please
until next time I'm Ryan I'm David thank
you for watching